buenas aunque aquí en el oeste del país
parecía que los estados de esta zona se
estaban librando de la peor parte de la
pandemia ahora california asegura que va
a iniciar un 'toque de queda' este
sábado a partir de las 10 de la noche
hasta las 5 de la mañana y que durará un
mes esto lo anunció el gobernador gabino
son después de asegurar que los casos de
coronavirus los test positivos han
aumentado en un 50% en tan sólo dos
semanas mientras que en este último mes
han aumentado un 60% las
hospitalizaciones por enfermedades
relacionadas con el móvil y es que los
dueños de bares restaurantes teatros
aseguran que esta puede ser la estocada
final en lo que viene siendo una lenta
agonía desde que comenzó la pandemia
aunque eso sí también es verdad que se
veía venir desde hace por lo menos un
mes mes y medio ya que se iban
imponiendo cada vez más restricciones a
este tipo de locales